there are two Army Colonels have been
arrested in the Democratic Republic of
Congo following the killing of more than
46 people the demonstrators were shot
during a military Crackdown in the
eastern city of Goma the group were
protesting against a U.N peacekeeping
Mission there which they say has failed
to tackle armed groups a government
delegation is in the city to investigate
those killings
after a long consultation with different
military groups as instructed by the
president of the DRC I am able to
announce to the public that two Colonels
have been arrested immediately one from
the presidential special unit and the
other from the Army in charge of the
troops in the town a quick Court martial
will be organized in the coming hours
it does seem uh Alan that the residents
of the area are sending a very clear
message to the authorities in terms of a
shutdown
yeah exactly this is what is happening
right now this is just one of the
pressure that the the population of Doma
mainly the youth movement and the laws
also Civil Society promised to maintain
up to the day they will get a serious
result from the authorities even though
this outcome that we are talking about
right now the arrest of these two
Colonel we have been discussing with
some of members of this group for
example they are saying these are just
Colonel they do believe that this this
city this province in general is under
the leadership of the military
authorities means generals and other
officials they still waiting for top
official officials to be uh taken to the
court as the the delegation from
Kinshasa promised that a martial Court
will be organized very soon that's
definitely the the way for civil society
to maintain the pressure and they're
still maintaining and the population are
following what is going on as we can see
right now so shut down and also the
movements are very low in the town just
the result of what has happened last
week indeed two military officials
arrested so far and obviously a lot of
disquiet in the community they want to
see more people held to account do you
think that is likely
foreign
this is the doubt of many people because
what we are we have been seeing right
now in this town the city is under the
state of Siege which is there is a huge
controversy around this uh special uh uh
Governors under the leadership of the
military people have been complaining
already for the uh the the withdrawal of
these Majors taken by the president
since two years passed and now with this
situation they are really not believing
that a general who is the commander of
the operation at the same time the
governor of this province will be uh
taken to the court for example but this
is why they are promising they're saying
we will maintain the pressure because we
know that this Colonel those two
Colonials they did not reacted for
themselves they were sent by someone and
they want to know who sent them exactly
to crack down on the on the civilian so
that they can they can seize as a result
of their struggle this is what they are
waiting for but it's as uncertain so far
due to the to the situation in the town
this prove is still under the threat and
the military still governing The
Province and the president is not
showing the sign of removing these
Majors very soon we will have to see
what how things will move in the coming
days indeed and we'll follow events with
you as time progresses for the moment
Alan Walker the in-go but thank you